what about mood do you ever drink in a
dark place so I broke I I had a chick
break up or I checked cheat on me
uh when I was when I came back from
Russia and she's talking with my best
friend
and I didn't know how to deal with the
emotions I had and my buddy Mike Osborne
said I can tell you this if you drink
they go away and I went okay
and that was the first and kind of last
time I ever did that
because I did it I've done it I've done
it a couple times but it I try to avoid
I try to avoid if there's emotion going
to alcohol like meaning not when it's
anxiety but like depression yeah I kind
of sit in the depression because or
anxiety I lean towards alcohol like
anxiety like about flying or or
just like getting worked up on over
something
but with depression I try to avoid
alcohol and just sit in it
um because I I because I've gone there
before but anxiety is up I land I land
all the time but depression heartbreak
all that you just sit in the feeling
yeah heartbreak's a weird one for me so
like the last time I got my heart broken
it Leanne dumped me
um we were dating for like four months
and she broke up with me and my instinct
was to have a drink my friends went to
this uh this middle eastern restaurant
and I told him what was going on in my
buddy of course like let's get a
cocktail and I was like I don't want one
I gotta figure this out because I want
this chick and if I start drinking I'll
be like ah [__] it
so I gotta figure it out like I wonder
I'm gonna find out my dad dies one day
or my mom but my dad will be the ruffle
my mom will be equally as rough my dad
and I were really close
and I wonder if I've thought about this
a lot if I'll have a drink
dealing with that
like I think about that a lot I keep
saying everything I get with my dad is
extra my dad my dad had a 100 blockage
in his Widowmaker twice and both times
they saved his life and they got a stint
I think 12 or 13 years ago and then he
just got a stint this last year
but that's why everything I get to do I
feel like is extra and so you know he
was just at the premiere of my movie and
he got to see that and he had a very
emotional response
and I got I got that from him and I was
like that that's a little icing on the
cake I did you know the arena in Tampa
was the first time you ever saw me do
stand up that was like a little extra so
all these things I'm getting with them
are all extra so I have you know at
least 74 so
yeah that'll be a tough one well at the
premiere here's what proud yeah he came
out he was sobbing crying and he goes
I've underestimated you your whole life
and I was like what he was like and he
just and he was shaking yeah he goes I
just underestimated you I didn't know I
didn't know that you I didn't know you
were this I didn't do whatever it was
really hard to understand him to be
honest with you I don't know totally
what he said he might just not like the
movie
I I think you uh were hearing what you
wanted to hear uh would you learn about
life from your father
uh it's not gonna make sense
I want I feel like sometimes I'm like a
professional [__] wrestler because
all I care about is you come and see me
do stand up so whatever I got to do to
get you there but
the number one thing my one takeaway
from that man's humility and
I applied I've applied it in different
ways throughout my career
on my 26th birthday he gave me a really
uh aggressive speech
he
I I was hungover and I just thought he
was going to say good happy birthday so
I picked up the phone
and I was like Hey and he was like you
are a tremendous piece of [__]
and he broke me off you have no humility
you ever know this you'll never succeed
in anything you you're you're lying to
yourself you're lying to everyone around
you you're not doing what you're going
after your dream I broke you I failed
you as a father this and that I was like
I thought you're gonna wish me happy
birthday
and so
in that speech he told me if I wanted
something I had to go at it and I had to
go after it as as hard as I could
and I had to do whatever it could I
could do to achieve that in this case it
was working offering to do anything at
the comedy club to get on stage
he told me I told him that's not how it
works and he said no that's how it works
for some poor kid from Harlem
because that kid needs it he goes you've
grown up with privilege your whole life
you don't need it you think you're going
to be fine
and so I went
and I ended up getting a job at the door
but I
it was it was it was it's humbling it's
really like uh it's it makes me feel it
made me feel uncomfortable
and so that humility
uh is the first time I really understood
humility and I've applied that in many
respects in like in like getting to be a
paid regular at The Comedy Store that
happened late in life for me and which I
think most people would give up and be
like ah [__] that I'm already a touring
comic I'm on TV I don't need that but
it's something I wanted and I knew I
wanted so I I just humbly went after it
and then I think I I still apply it when
it comes to
selling tickets or or selling a project
to the fans
or even doing podcasts I try to be as
honest as I can about whatever I'm going
through or whatever I'm dealing with but
when it comes to like selling things I
don't I don't have a problem
trying to make fun of myself or or
get in front of people so that they know
that that I have a show because the
thing I'm good at though
the one thing I know I'm good at stand
up and and I I say that humbly but like
I want them to come there so like I've
heard people make fun of me like before
they're like yeah I'm not some I'm not
some clown in a speedo who's one is
gonna I'm a real comic and I go okay but
I wanna I want them that my shows and
you can be that guy and I'll be this guy
yeah the clown the speedo yeah it's like
what are you gonna do
funny people make fun of me for taking
my shirt off like I guess behind my back
no one ever does it to me like no one
would ever
Comics aren't Comics aren't Comics
aren't that manly
yeah yeah but I always go like I always
go like who what do you care what am I
what do you care